[Musique]
mais c'est ce à quoi vous pouvez y est
accusé de détournement de fonds pour 50
millions euros d'accord jusqu'à ce soir
au mans sélection tu vois ta petite
valise la mode se mettre dedans et j'ai
beaucoup trop petit nain dans cette
autre europe observés en face à rentrer
mais là c'est évidemment présent outin
il ya un nouveau collègue pour toi ma
soi disant fermait pour atteinte à
l'intégrité physique d'un groupe de
personne alors qu'en fait c'est juste
une agression à la grenade
[Musique]
tu me lis et en mer doit lui coûta d un
roman ouais il m'a dit un gros mot
bonne nuit copains quand je vais d'or
falloir que j'achète une identité
dark vador à quoi et tu es noir dark
vador je suis
on se revoit d'or mais bien sûr qu'on se
remet à dos comment je fais pour te
retrouver
je serai dans la nuit un mickaël vador
ouais voilà c'est ça mais michael mann a
pour moi c'est quand tu veux ta réponse
au ping pong en train de bosser sur un
anneau futurs mariés comme thierry ses
clips rien série c'est pour le
calendrier à côté pour contrôler ma voix
et basse ici carrément aussi et a fait
tous les week-ends de france
puisqu'on aime beaucoup comme en bas oui
je me suis rangé ses repas que j'ai fait
de la prison avec toi fais pas de gare
je vais me tenir
poutine un ami de passage poutine
poutine vladimir poutine ou foutez de ma
gueule
poutine on n'est plus en prison en
dehors ça se passe pas comme ça au grand
match
tout allait bien dans ma vie jusqu'à ce
que tu débarques je vais tout perdre à
cause de tes conneries
je n'ai pas démilitarisées ainsi à klaus
coach